Faux.
Dans cette société multiculturelle, intersectionnelle,
où nous sommes réunis et élevés
par des gens dont la bienséance est différente de la nôtre,
quand nous ne partageons pas la même bienséance,
les normes tacites entraînent des problèmes
alors que les règles éphémères
nous permettent des rapports pleins de sens.
Ce sont des constitutions à usage unique pour un objectif particulier.
Un dîner d'équipe
où différentes générations se réunissent
et ne partagent pas les mêmes postulats sur les téléphones :
le premier qui regarde son téléphone
paye la note.
(Rires)
Essayez.
(Applaudissements)
Pour un cercle de conseil d'entrepreneurs entre inconnus,
quand les animateurs ne veulent pas simplement écouter
l'investisseur en capital de risque --
(Rires)
cela sent le vécu --
vous ne pouvez pas révéler ce que vous faites comme travail.
Pour un dîner entre mères
où vous voulez renverser les normes
de ce dont les femmes qui sont mères parlent quand elles se réunissent,
si vous parlez de vos enfants, vous buvez un verre.
(Rires)
C'est un vrai dîner.
Les règles sont formidables
car elles nous permettent
de changer et d'harmoniser temporairement les comportements.
Dans des sociétés diversifiées,
les règles éphémères ont une force particulière.
Elles permettent de se rassembler au-delà des différences,
de nouer des liens,
de créer du sens ensemble
sans avoir à être les mêmes.
Quand j'étais enfant,
je naviguais entre mes deux mondes comme un caméléon.
Si quelqu'un éternuait dans la maison de ma mère,
je disais : « A tes souhaits »,
chez mon père : « Que Dieu te bénisse ».
Pour me protéger, je me cachais,
comme tant d'entre nous le font.
Ce n'est qu'après avoir grandi et travaillé sur les conflits
que j'ai arrêté de me cacher.
J'ai réalisé que pour moi, les meilleurs rassemblements
nous permettent d'être au milieu des autres,
d'être vus tels que nous sommes
et de voir.
Notre façon de nous réunir importe
car notre façon de nous réunir
est notre façon de vivre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)